- Introducing the Nike Air Proposal 1s,
for the guy who doesn't want to crease
his special sneakers on his special day.
After my first failed proposal, I knew
I had to get to work on the Air Proposal 1s.
- [Off-camera:] This is so cute I'm gonna cry. What the
hell, Jamel? Dude.
- No. No.
- [Off-camera:] No.
What—what are you doing?
- Equipped with state-of-the-art
nuptial technology,
the Proposal 1s have anti-crease
accordion material that ensure
you can keep both of your
shoes on like a goddamn normal person
when it's time to get
down and pop the question.
Our team spent countless hours
reviewing and evaluating every
rejected proposal by embarrassing
sneakerheads across the globe.
And we're happy to say we're
proud of the end result.
Sure,
this shoe costs three times what you
spent on her ring, but I won't tell
her if you don't.
- Look, I warned him:
If he took one shoe off when he proposed,
I would probably say no and leave his ass.
- Inspired by the Jordan 10, the bottom
features every important date in your
relationship's history because we
know you forgot them. With these, she'll
know you're soulmates. The Nike Air Proposal
1: Start your relationship off on
the right foot—and don't get your ass left.